翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
これ 何だと思いますか？
（会場）コマ
（緑川）正解！聞くまでもないですよね
そのとおりコマです
これは日本の町工場が
作ってます
今日はこのコマが起こした奇跡のお話を
みなさんに聞いて頂きたいと思います
これよーく見ると
すっごくきれ～なコマです
画面で見てもわかるとは思うんですけども
なんでこんなにきれいに回るか？
これは精度が良いからです
精度を出す
日本の町工場の職人がいるから
こんなにきれいなコマが 出来上がる
ということなんです
でこの コマを持ち寄り
ケンカゴマで戦って
日本一を決めるという大会があります
それが「全日本製造業コマ大戦」
という取り組みであります
でこのコマ大戦
腕自慢の町工場が直径２センチに
自社のプライドそして
職人の意地をかけ
戦います
大の大人が
勝てば喜び 負けたら悔しがり
優勝すれば涙をする
という大会です
で最大の屈辱は
負けたら没収なんです
取られちゃうんです
どれだけ良い材料を使おうが
どれだけ手間ひまかけようが
負けたら没収
（笑）
その日の優勝者がすべての
コマを総取りするというルール
エクストリームでしょ？
で今日は
この町工場
みなさんは どういうイメージをお持ちか
聞いてみたいんですけど
例えば 汚いとか
危ないとか
暗いとか
もうひとつ
経営が不安定
なんていうのもあるかもしれません
実は僕も
町工場に勤めてて
リストラされた経験があります
14年前の話ですけど
20歳から勤めて
35になった時
会社がなくなってしまいました
みなさんならどうします？
来月から収入がなくなります
家族を養わなければならない
再就職をしようか？
いっそのこと起業してしまおうか？
散々悩みました
３日間だけですけど
（笑）
その間にやったことは
一緒にリストラされた仲間に聞きました
「もし俺が会社を起こしたら
一緒にやってくれるか？」
「いいですよ」
「でも いつ給料払えるか分かんない」
「いいですよ」と
「さらには君たちから
お金を借りなければならない
それでもいいか？」
「うーん いいですよ」
と言ってくれました
同じ時期に
地域の先輩経営者にも
相談に行きました
地域のリーダー的存在です
そのリーダーがこう言いました
「うちにくるか？
給料50万でいいか？」
「50万くれるんですか？！」
行っちゃおうかなって思ったんですけれども
同時にそのリーダーは こうも言いました
「もし君を雇ったとしたら
若い芽を摘むことになるかもな」
そのとき僕にはこう聞こえました
ひょっとして
起業したら会社を作ったら
この人と同じ土俵に上がれる？
「オレはそれを待っている」
っていう風に聞こえたんですね
これを「うるわしき勘違い」って
言うんですけれど
そんな訳で
会社を作りました
ですが町工場の経営は
様々な課題があります
会社を作ったばかりの時は
目先の仕事をやるので精一杯でした
でも心の中では
「このままじゃだめだ 」
「何とかしなきゃいけない」
っていう思いでした
うちの会社は幸い
10年以上存続していますが
この先 10年 20年 30年考えたら
自分の会社だけが存続するっていうのは
やはりあり得ない
町工場 製造業
全体が盛り上がらなければ
うちの会社もいずれ
なくなってしまうだろう
という風に考えるようになりました
そのときに出てきた取り組みが
このコマ大戦なんです
で コマ大戦
４年前から始めてます
第１回目のときは
21チーム集まってくれました
その日の夜のテレビニュースにもなり
全国から問い合わせが殺到しました
これはえらいことになる
ということで第２回目をやるにあたって
日本を７ブロックに分け
地方予選をやって
その勝者を招いて決勝戦を行う
ということにしました
その時の地方予選の参加チームは
200チームになりました
そして2015年
去年には３回目の大きな大会を
やることができました
それが「世界コマ大戦」です
今コマ大戦
大きな大会から小さな大会含めると
年間50場所やっております
これコマ大戦一つの大会のことを
相撲にちなんで
「場所」って呼んでいるんですけど
50場所
ということは
まぁほぼ毎週どっかで
全国のどこかでコマ大戦が行なわれている
という状況になっています
そしてこの世界コマ大戦は
日本を含め７カ国集まって頂きました
来場者は6000人
マスコミの数
これ後ろに映っているの全部マスコミです
40社ぐらい集まって頂いた
非常に大きなイベントとなりました
でその
世界コマ大戦やったときのエピソードを
２つばかりお話ししたいと思います
１つ目は
この世界大戦を開催する費用
1800万円かかるという見積もりが出ました
大金です
町工場にとってはすごいお金です
大会が間近に迫ってもまだ
1000万足りません
実行委員も周りのみんなも
「どうすんだ！」と言ってきます
そのときに僕が答えられたのは
「僕にはお金がない
あるのは会社だけだ
もしお金が足りなくなるのなら
会社を売ってでもこの大会運営費にする」
と言いました
同じ時期 熊本でコマ大戦がありました
そこへ出張したときに
熊本コマ大戦の実行委員長が
僕を神社に連れて行ってくれました
金運アップの神社です
そこでお賽銭を投げ入れ
絵馬に「世界コマ大戦 成功しますように」
と書いてきました
するとどうでしょう？
みるみる協賛金が集まり始めました
最終的にはちょい黒字になりました
すごいでしょ？この神社
この神社詳しく知りたいでしょ？
でも今日はその話はしません
（笑）
皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
日本にはこんなことわざがあります
「人事を尽くして天命を待つ」
まさにこんな心境でした
やることはすべてやった
会社を売る覚悟までできた
あとは天にまかせるのみだ
みなさんも同じような経験が
あるかもしれません
でも僕がね
さらに思うにはこうなんです
「人事を尽くして
天命を
奪い取る！」
「人事を尽くして天命を奪い取る！」
ぐらいの
気迫が必要なんじゃないかな
ということを思いました
そしてこの
先ほど言った
熊本コマ大戦の
実行委員長の彼
実は残念なんですけども
昨年末に亡くなってしまいました
急な話だったんですけどね
彼は僕のことを 会長と呼んでくれてました
「会長 九州のコマ大戦は僕に任せて下さい
近々桜島大戦ができそうです」と
メッセージをくれたばかりでした
彼の葬儀に出た時には棺の上に
コマ大戦に出た時の
トレードマークの帽子と
全国で優勝した時の
トロフィーが置かれていました
ご家族の配慮で
彼がコマ大戦のテレビ取材を受けたときの
ビデオも上映してくれてました
まだ50歳
志半ばで
悔しかったでしょう
せめてもの救いは
彼の寝た顔が
穏やかだったことです
そして
このコマも実は
その彼が
生前僕にくれたものです
今となっては
形見です
人はいつ死ぬかわからない
だからこそ
このコマを握り締め
残りの命の使い方
無駄にはできないな
そう思いました
もう一つのエピソードです
世界コマ大戦の予選会は
全国 世界中で
やっていただきました
そのときに一番早くやって頂いた国が
ボリビアという国でした
ボリビアは 南米最貧国と呼ばれてます
そこの17歳と27歳が
ボリビアチャンピオンになりました
その彼らが こう言いました
「僕たちが作ったコマを 日本へ送るから
代わりにだれか回して下さい」と
そりゃそうです
お金ないんです
日本に来れないんです
そういうような話を
ある懇親会でしていたところ
一人のおばちゃんが
立ち上がりました
「その２人を日本へ呼ぼう
私が募金を集めるから」
まあなんとおせっかいでしょう
（笑）
ボリビアからの渡航費
ひとり30万かかるんです
直行便はありません
飛行機 何回も乗り換えなければならない
その子たちの親でさえ
外国に行ったことないんです
もし日本に来て
帰ってこなかったらどうしよう？
心配で心配でしょうがない
ボリビア政府にも
何枚も何枚も召喚状書かなきゃいけない
なんておせっかいだ
でもそのおばちゃん
やっちゃったんですよ
なんと90万集めました
そのお金でチケットを買って
ボリビアに送り
コマだけではなく
その彼らを呼ぶことができた
おせっかいなおばちゃんが
女神に見えました
実はそのボリビアという国
僕にとっては
特別な思い入れがあるんです
それは 約50年前なんですけども
キューバ革命を起こした人がいます
その人が キューバ革命を起こした後
政治家にはならず
「自分の職業は 生涯革命家である」と言って
外国の特に搾取されているような国を
助けに行こうと世界に行くんですね
かっこいいでしょう？
僕のあこがれなんですよ
その彼が1967年
39歳の時に
革命に失敗し命を落とした国が
ボリビアなんです
そのボリビアからメールが来ました
「ボリビアでコマ大戦を開きたいんです
コマ大戦を使って
ボリビアの工業を発展させたいんです」って
メールが届いたんです
それを読んだとき 僕は
その革命家からの手紙かと思いました
うるわしき勘違い２つ目です
ボリビアでコマ大戦をやってもらうために
この土俵とコマのサンプルを送りました
土俵の上には日本語とスペイン語で
「ボリビアの諸君 日本で待っている」
そして 日本の国旗とボリビアの国旗を
印刷して送りました
その土俵を使って
ボリビア大会を開いて頂き
チャンピオンを招くことができたんです
その招いた２人からも
プレゼントを頂きました
この写真
真ん中僕ですよ
真ん中僕です
この開いて持ってるやつ
これ盾なんです
ボリビア工業会からいただいた盾です
スペイン語で書いてあるんですけど
「これ何て書いてあんの？」と聞いたら
「あなたはボリビアと日本の工業を
結びつけた偉い人だ」
と書いてあるらしいです
そしてこの衣装
ニット帽にひざ丈のセーターです
これは17歳の少年が
自分の少ない小遣いで
買ってきてくれたプレゼントです
これはいったいどういう服だ？
って聞いたところ
これはボリビアの大統領が着る服だ
でそんな服もらっていいの
そんな服着ていいの？って聞いたら
「いいんだ あなたもプレジデントだから」
って言ってくれました
ある意味
僕があこがれた革命家
志半ばで逝ってしまった革命家が
志した
ほんの一部ですが
コマ大戦を使って
手伝えたのではないかなって
思っているんですけど
言いすぎ過ぎですかね？
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
ボリビアをはじめとする世界コマ大戦に来て
日本の職人と出会ったこの子たちが
将来 自国の工業を発展させ
10年 20年 30年後
「その成功は何だった？」って聞かれた時に
「いや 実はコマ大戦に出たからだ」って
言ってくれたら最高の喜びです
そして仲間を信じ
自分を信じ
そして連鎖を信じる
すると
国も
言葉も
時代さえも越えて
その思いは伝わり
世界のどこかで達成される
まさに
奇跡ではないでしょうか？
以上 コマが起こした奇跡のお話でした
ありがとうございました
（拍手）